beth i'm sorry about the mix-up with the
um
the agenda but when you put in
an email and then there's a little pdf
box in the bottom i can never open that
i'll look into that after i will um
and see if there's a reason why okay
if you go to the top of the al afro
usually
you can click on the top and it some
work all right right now
i thought it was being really
technically good
sometimes it if there is um something to
say
download the whole message then you can
yeah yeah but
um in on this occasion and a couple of
others
for licensing it hasn't worked at all
there isn't been one
i've had those before yeah i've found
the same thing too
i might be wrong but doesn't that put a
note in the calendar when you click on
that
icon does members we're now live
streaming the meeting so i'll hand over
to councillor hayes
um as vice chair to start the meeting
thank you
good morning and welcome to the very
first 2021 licensing
and regulator committee for team bridge
council
all participants are are taking part
remotely
and we are now live streaming on youtube
please make sure that all microphones
are muted when not speaking
to avoid any background noise levels and
if you wish to comment
just please raise your hand and wait to
be called
and when it comes to a vote the officer
will read out members names
and then would you please say if you are
voting for against
or abstaining can i just introduce
officers which is andrea furnace who i
believe we can only listen to at the
moment
there's maria downing which is the legal
advisor there's both tepton the
democratic service assistant and chris
morgan who's a trainee democratic
service
officer and the various
that we have around uh i believe all
have their names in the bottom left-hand
corner
i don't think there's any need to
introduce any of them
and we'll go straight to the agenda
item one apologies for absence apologies
from councillors rolison and councillors
cox chair
thank you uh moving on to item two any
declarations of interest
none at all i can see that uh go to item
three
which is the minutes of the meetings on
the 14th of october 2020
the 29th of october 2020 and the 26th of
november
2020. um i hope you all had a good read
and absorb them
i need a proposal and a second are there
for those
happy to propose thank you
second thank you mike
second lead uh councillor mike hocking
we now proceed to item agenda for which
is the hackney carriage and private hire
policy
um the statutory taxi and private hire
vehicle standards
and we have andrea to present it to the
committee and we need a proposal in the
secondary afterwards
so over to you andrea thank you thank
you
good morning you have before you a
report in relation
to changes that are required to our
hackney
encourage a higher policy to enable us
to meet the statutory and private hire
vehicle standards that came into effect
on the 20th of july 2020
all authorities are expected to provide
an update
by the 31st of january in how we will be
proposing to develop and initiate the
standards
our current we carrying private pulley
requirements to be able to carry out
some of the changes
these don't require to go out to
consultation
these are additional five-year license
for the operator license holders which
currently only states one year
the disclosure and bar and service check
to include for new applicants and
renewals
that they sign up to the ds update
service
that will allow us to carry out the six
monthly
checks this check is carried out every
three
years and we're looking at actual
introduction to
with current drivers that they'd be
requested to sign up on the renewal of
their dbs because obviously we've had
people that have done dbs's since july
it would seem um not very professional
to expect them to pay out another
six pound for a dbs just so they can
sign up to the update
service because there's a time limit in
which the dbs certifier is issued
for them to be able to sign up to the
update service so we're going to do the
using to do renewals as their dbs comes
up for renewal
but if approved by committee today
new drivers will be expected to sign up
as soon as their dbs certificate is
issued
this will be a reduced cost for the
driver
and to sign up to the update service it
costs them 13 pounds a year
as opposed to 56 pounds every three
years
um which is what they currently pay
however if they don't sign up to the
update service
six months time they will have to pay
the 56 pound to do a new
dbs certificate so that's another change
we're looking
to to add um next one is licenses
licensees currently provide licensing
at seven days if they are convicted
or charged of any offence um
we're looking to check that to 48 hours
as set out in the standards
there's also um to subscribe
to the national anti-fraud network
this is a single point of access for the
national
taxi license revocations and refusals
known as nr3 this is another tool for
licensing to be satisfied
that an applicant is fit and proper to
hold a driver's license issued by this
authority
this is possibly looking to be made
mandatory
by the local government association
moving forward
because obviously if this is a national
register for any
drivers that we're applying down this
end of the country
we will be able to check the register to
make sure that they haven't been refused
or have their licences revoked
in another authority so we want to add
that part to the policy
we're also looking that members adopt
the standard
when deciding on whether a fit and
proper person
comes when the joint an applicant comes
before you
to think about whether or not they're a
fit or proper person
and we base the information on a
question
that would be would you allow a person
for whom you care
regardless of their condition to travel
alone
in a vehicle driven by this person at
any time
night or day if on the balance of
probabilities
the answer is no the individual should
not hold a license
if the committee or delegated officer is
only 50
50 after the applicant or licensee
is fit and proper they should not hold a
licence
this will be added to future reports
for members to consider so we'd like
that bit to be
adopted to allow us to put that into
courts
and then the complaints
currently in our policy it's updating
because we've got an online complaints
form now
so that information just flight to date
so it'll just
bring its speed with the national
standards
all the other remaining matters stated
in the appendix will be included
as part of the review of policy which is
planned for this year
there was also one other additional to
be added to the position it's relating
to
we we do it so it's fine but we just
need to put it into the policy
basically relating that we issue
licenses to individuals that are
actually on the board list
when it comes from the dbs though
chairman permission is sought to allow
the amendments to the current policy as
stated in the report
thank you andrew uh is there any
questions there from the committee at
all
i think um councillor silvia russell
with the hand was up first
yes uh uh just a query on paragraph
eight point seven to eight point twelve
paragraph eight point eight
it's about the proposal to make it an
additional granting an operator license
to require a register of all staff that
will take bookings or dispatch
vehicles is kept does that mean they
have to be dbs checked as well the staff
people on the phone taking the party yes
they do but that
will be part of the com that will have
to go to consultation and
we'll form part of the review of the
policy
right even though they may not be in
touch with it with any passengers at all
you know they're only if they take if
they're taking
bookings they're involved with
passengers i say
okay thank you
uh councillor john nutley thank you
thank you chair
um yeah just a couple of things about
you covered one of the things that i was
going to
ask about was the dbs checks um i see on
that
on in seven uh vehicle licensing
um i see on their reference to cctv
i know it's not mandatory uh according
to the uh
point that's in there um is that not a
bit concerning
having cctv i know they say having cctv
in the cab i know it could protect the
driver
and maybe passengers such but i was just
thinking like
if there's children etc in the vehicle
or anything like that
and then on um 8.13
uh record keeping um
we'll just bring it over may whoops not
too far
on on the record uh record keeping do
do uh all the drivers is asking the name
of the passenger the time of the request
the pickup point the destination
are those records kept by all the
drivers on those
no they're they're the first on the cctv
there's a boner contention
it will form part of the posse review
um so the decision to be made there
there's there's um
legal issues implicated to that so we're
being very careful
about how that's into the public because
obviously
um it's all to do with the data
controller and things like that we don't
want to be the data controller we don't
want to be responsible for the records
that they're holding they should be
dexterous as
a lot of legal matters before we get
that right
and put to the policy but that will form
part of the review of the policy
in relation to the record-keeping that's
for
private hires and it's the company that
takes the bookings
that will require all that information
and keep that information
okay thank you very much thank you can i
can i just add to that
the um requisite uh provisions that
operators have to comply to is actually
laid out in legislation
and i think there needs to be a greater
understanding that actually operators as
well as drivers
have a part to play in the licensing
regime and it's very important that they
too
because they hold information such as
which passengers are being picked up
which properties might be empty who's
taking who where there's
it's proved from recent cases that have
come to light that operators
have their part to play in relation to
safeguarding
and also in relation to risk so
therefore the requirements on the
operators are being slightly tightened
as well as those on the drivers and just
to back up what andrea said in relation
to the cctv
that's obviously a huge area open for
discussion
that's not um for discussion today that
will be part of our policy review
the consideration around whether as a
licensing authority
that is something that we consider
necessary or not
and all the fors and against will be put
um
to the members at the time the report
the policy decision is is made
it's as andrew indicated a huge issue
and there are
plus and minus points and there's going
to be people who feel strongly that it
should be
allowed and those that you know feel
strongly it shouldn't um there's
obviously lots of potential data
protection issues
and um looking at things such as
proportionality in the need but
that's a discussion for another day
really so
unless there's anything else to add
andrea i hope you don't mind me butting
in but
what you said and i just had something
about the record keeping isn't that
all those records kept at the office so
to speak when they
they walk in so the driver doesn't have
to do that it's all
by the admin staff within the company
that's my belief
if it's but if it's booked through
beyonce
yes they would hold all the records if
i made sure just another quick one on
that on the record keeping
how does that cover with the operators
and data protection
i've seen that follow the same rules as
everybody else really
are you happy in relation to data
protection it's a
it's um there's a statutory requirement
on the operator to take
to hold those records so therefore it's
um the date the data is held for a
statutory purpose
as long as the operator obviously only
uses that information for the purpose
so you phone up to put your taxi as long
as that operator is only holding that
information
for those purposes then you know under
data protection it's totally
justifiable and accepted purpose if they
go off selling it to
sainsbury's or something that's a
different issue but yeah
it's um it's for a legal reason that
they're collecting that information so
thank you very much thank you council
mark hocking
you voted
yeah thank you uh chair uh just a couple
of points um
the we've got to remember that the cctv
and i appreciate what our legal advisors
just said that
it will be within a consultation
situation
but we have to remember it's not only
there for the safety of the passenger
but
also there for the safety of the driver
and we also got to remember too that
most public transport vehicles now i.e
buses
has cctv we were in them and um
from what i can gather i've never i've
not heard any problems
apart from the fact that anybody trying
to commit a crime one of us is the ones
that
now get picked up on the cctv i've
looked through this and to be fair um mr
chairman
um i think that the the situation the
bits that's being altered
are for the safety of all and therefore
i think we should adopt it
uh and i'm more than happy to propose
that we adopt those said hey
thank you mike um sylvia you got your
hand up
you muted sylvia
off on its own um you know in my
experience when we've interviewed
drivers a lot of them are not
are not english speakers uh primarily
um it's a big responsibility for drivers
and a bit onerous for them
all this i can understand this has come
from county lines and we've got to have
protection and all the rest of it
but it does seem to me to be putting a
great responsibility and an owner's
responsibility
on the driver um
well let's see what comes back from the
consultation i i
i just think it's just one more step to
to really uh keeping somebody
inhibited from doing their job really
and and
assuming that everybody is guilty before
they're before they even start
that's i think they're already
safeguarding isn't it
yes you need to go to the top
so i've got not only the driver but also
the occupants too
well if i can just perhaps chair
explain that yes the standards have been
introduced as a result of obviously the
rotherham
you know numerous cases in relation to
safeguarding um
there is an expectation on the local
authorities that these standards will be
adopted
um they are for the protection of
everybody
not just the vulnerable people which is
what they ate primarily
they were aimed at doing but actually
their protection of all the traveling
public
yes there is more onus on a driver but
it's a licensable activity
and therefore with any licensable
activity their requirements to be met
for the protection of
those people that are coming into
contact with um the other thing i'd add
is
as i previously said there's the
expectation that these standards will be
adopted
um by all licensing authorities it
will make things less challengeable for
us
than it may do if we chose not to adopt
them because there's certainly the
expectation for central government there
and it also um allows um
a greater information sharing and
licensing authorities were
working together um as andrew indicated
earlier we're starting to notice
obviously we're down here in the
southwest
so we're slightly out of the way but we
have started to notice as a licensing
authority that we're getting
applications
from you know to 300 miles away for
drivers that have been licensed
in central london or liverpool and
that can cause concern as to why they're
coming you know they're not necessarily
residing down here and
suddenly they're applying to us for
licenses this will help us as an
authority just deal with
i think more clarity and uh being a bit
more robust
in general with our licensing regime um
i don't know if you've got anything else
to add andrea but
i think
we've always had a very good
relationship with the taxi drivers
in our area and um i do hope that some
protection will be afforded to the
drivers
as well as the passengers because um
i i just have some concerns that quite a
lot of our drivers
you know are not english spoken as a
main language
and uh it's just a bit onerous i feel
for them and i hope that they'll get the
protection onto this new legislation as
well
no more questions proposal
do we have a second up happy new second
and chairman
thank you uh consonantly so then we'll
go to
the vote then so um
beth can you read that uh the names and
please could you indicate if you're
voting for against or explaining
councillor bradford or
councillor clarence
councillor evans or councillor hawking
or councillor kurzweil
councillor care as well
thank you pardon four councillor nutley
four councillor russell oh
councillor hayes oh i'm married
yes carricher thank you
right let's move on now to five
which is a request for a private hire
vehicle extension
on vehicle license lf05
ymz and i believe the applicant
is ready to speak on this just
can you uh introduce andrew please
yeah that's fine are we all present
the applicant president yes yes good
morning
good morning good morning good morning
um we're here today to to the
tickle extensions the first one is a
request
from claire street for a red volkswagen
transporter which is 50 years
and not nine months of age the vehicle
was viewed by the license
on the 16th of december months and
photos are included in the report
vehicle um
sorry the failed the depot inspection
on the 4th of january this was based on
the vehicle being sawn and therefore
currently does not have any tax
notice was on the 25th of january
committee are asked that in this request
thank you any questions from the
committee
foreign
would you like to add anything good
morning claire
by the way would you like to add
anything to that um
i just wanted to explain about why the
vehicle is sawn at the moment
um it's um a transporter mini bus
which is used primarily for taking
passengers to the
airport obviously at the moment
we're not taking anyone to any airports
um so
financially wise we have sawn it because
obviously the tax is quite a lot of
money
each month when the vehicle is laid up
in our car park
we are hoping fingers crossed like
everybody else once the vaccine has
been rolled out come this summer we'll
the vehicle will be
back in use again up and down the uh
motorway up to
heathrow and gatwick and back working so
um
but for the moment we've got it sawn um
because it's saving us money basically
while it's not being used
thank you claire so any questions
yes john council john notley thank you
chair uh
morning clara well i mean looking
looking on the documents here i see
the well the last mlt certificate i've
got in front of me
was for the 28th of june 2019
they presumably there was one for the
for last year
on that side and what did concern me
was the offside rear tire cracking
and perished now i presume after i mean
that was back in
2019 presumably that has obviously been
changed and i presume
there is a current mlt certificate
um yes and because of coronavirus we
were given a six-month extension
to the mot um the
mot is now uh due on the 25th of january
unfortunately we haven't been able to
have it done prior to this meeting
because
you can only have it done a month before
which would have been 25th of december
obviously christmas day was the first
day we could have it done
and the mot station that we go to didn't
have any availability
until after today um it had a taxi test
on monday which basically is the same as
an mot
and it passed that with line colours
with no advisory
thank you very much thank you thank you
any more questions
no well thank you um claire
okay if you go back into the waiting
room please
okay we have another another recap
and then uh after that we'll adjourn to
discuss the various applications and let
you know
thank you thank you very much thank you
uh we now move on to item agenda six a
guy acne
carriage vehicle extension vehicle
ml60w rx
which is just whistle on to mine
no give me a moment please i just whiz
along find out which one it is
just see it
andrea okay second request this morning
is from an adam azarski for a black sea
at alambra
the vehicle was 10 years and three
months of age the vehicle was viewed by
the lights and officer on the 7th of
december and the comments and photos are
included in the report
the vehicle passed its mot on the 17th
of december with no advisories
and passed the vehicle inspection on the
18th of december
with one advisory which was a
citizenship in the windscreen
the applicant will not be in attendance
chair committee or asked to determine
this request
thank you andre is any questions
no oh sorry lauren have you got your
hand up
yeah sorry i i don't have on this one
rob the
you know all that we usually get the
appendix that gives us all the mot
failures and things in the past all i've
got yes i notice that yeah the vehicle
inspection sheets is that an issue
got it here
yeah i've got it sorry um
no because we were submitted the vehicle
um mot itself so when we've got that we
don't always go in to get the full thing
but i can
get that if you i'm not fine
but i just i'm so used to seeing it that
way i just wondered if there's a reason
thank you andrew
no it's only if they send it to
certificate we use the certificate
but if they don't send it in then we
usually go into the the
dot gov website and go and view the mot
ourselves and get all the history but if
they submit it we use what they
submitted
okay thank you uh chairman there is a
vehicle inspection sheet here among the
papers is that
is that valid it's dated the 18th of the
12th 2020.
yeah that's a vehicle test inspection
any more questions no
and then we'll have to adjourn now this
these this meeting and
no decision will be made while we're
still in public
session so um beth if you can
take us off live uh broadcast
thank you chad i'll just get the
application back in just to explain that
to her that we won't
be returning just bear with me two
moments
so just to explain for the applicant and
any members of the public watching that
we will now be
uh stopping the live stream um for the
committee to make their decision
and we won't be coming back that will
once the decision is made that will be
the meeting over
and all applicants will be informed
later today of the decision made by the
committee
i will not be stopping the live
streaming okay thank you